hey everybody it's Mike from overflows
and in this video I'm going to talk
about a way to use volume profile that
you know is is kind of underutilized
um you know people always ask me what
else do I use in terms of technical
analysis besides uh a volume footprint
chart and volume profile sort of lends
in well with order flow and
the the problem though that I have with
volume profile is you know
most software started from the beginning
of the trading session and you know
really when I look at volume profile I
like to Anchor it from important moments
in the trading day right if you're
familiar with Brian Shannon you know
he's got he talks a lot about anchored V
web right and that's a very useful tool
as well but I like to use volume profile
and anchor it in sort of in the same
concept now again I'm not the one that
invented anchored profiles I'm not
claiming to be but it's a way that I use
um volume profile as opposed to looking
at the whole entire day you know because
you know once a number comes out or the
FED does something you know everything
changes and oftentimes
you know it's really going to be in your
better interest to sort of disregard
um you know what happened earlier right
for example
um this past Friday you know we had that
number it came out and obviously the
market dropped down right then the
market rallied back up and then it sold
off late in the day and if you're using
a volume profile that started you know
from the beginning of the the session
you know here you know what was
happening you know all up until this
time period is sort of irrelevant I want
to be tracking what's happening
um you know since this big number came
out or since an announcement came out or
um you know some political event
happened right and really what I'll be
looking at is you know swing highs and
swing lows or literally from the time
um the event happened and there are
tools out there
that you can use you know now with
um my order flow software I don't have
this tool built in you know I've been
working with Ninja caters to build a
bundle of their tools that is helpful to
Traders and one of them that they have
is this dynamic
volume profile and it's part of this
series you know the link is below in in
the comments section
um as part of their institutional Ed
series Dynamic volume profile right I
you can see I already have it on there
so what it does is it allows you to draw
a volume profile from you know a
particular point in time right this is
when the number came out to you know the
cash open right you want to see what the
volume was look at this right from the
time of the number Market dropped to the
cash open basically right here this is
what 833 I mean you could go back two
minutes here 831
okay it's I've got a couple levels here
you can see value area high value area
low that's this line right here this is
the value area low this value area high
this is the point of control what I'm
going to be looking for is to the right
side of the market you can see the
market went up went above the value Area
High
traded back into value and look at where
the market came down to it came right
back down to that point of control right
here this bar right and then a shot back
up imagine if you know these levels you
know beforehand you just drop a bit in
there saying okay if we come back down
here and test this point of control or
we test the value area low you know I
want to be a buyer
right or you know if we're going to
break out through the value area low you
know we already broke out to the value
area high but if we're going to come
back down and test this value very low
and break out past it you know maybe I
want to be short
but again you could anchor it from you
know any
significant point that you want right I
mean for me the most obvious are
um the cash open
um you know the 730 numbers that come
out
the high or the low or swing high or
swing low so you know if you were to
Anchor it from the cash open here so
this is again this is NASDAQ this is a
simple one minute chart I'm using this
bar chart instead of an order flow chart
because I could put more information
um you know here I just basically want
to show you this is from the cash open
to you know the first swing High okay
right here obviously the high of the day
is is higher but I'm just looking at it
from the cash open the number came out
at 7 30. cash opens at 8 30. it's the
most active time of trading you know
this is when everybody is is making
their decisions based off of what just
happened in the market in terms of the
economic number you can see this line
this black line right here this is the
point of control let's just extend it
out
right you can see how the market came
right back to that level when it got
within a couple of ticks bounced back up
you know you're talking
you know around 27 a half 28 you know
all the way back up into the 60s right I
didn't mean to get the 70s finally it
broke down broke out of this value area
low over here and kept selling off you
know we did make a little higher high
over here point of control more or less
the same price you can see how the
market came back down to it right and
you know you had that other high over
here but this was the higher one but
even if you draw that line out there
right again that point of control is
still holding that same level right
anchor it from the place okay so I mean
that's NASDAQ I mean take a look at uh
some other markets uh let me just
remove this one
um unless we got gold Gold's a great
Market you know gold very interesting
yeah the number came out boom Market
went ballistic
then went sideways tested the low and
then you tested that high again
okay
from this low you know it was at about 9
23 in the morning to the swing High
okay what do we got we got up here this
is the profile is kind of this uh
p-shaped I evaluate high up here value
area low down here you've got your point
of control up in here okay put a bunched
up near the high but I got this area
this target down here
okay opponent came down off the high
tested the point of control went back up
the value area high now it's testing the
opponent control it's breaking well
where's my target okay well I got this
area down here this red line this point
this value area low
okay
draw that line in there look at this it
it's trading back and forth late in the
day three o'clock in the afternoon came
within like a tick or two of that level
and bounce back up we'll see where it's
going to open Sunday it'll be
interesting to see how that uh how that
develops you know but again you know
this is
sort of the power of different ways of
using volume profile right you can you
don't have to take it from you know the
the open of the day all right let's go
back here if you were to draw it from
the open
okay you know this is where's the open
right here
so basically you're drawing it from
there to here well that's the high up
there
um if you're draw it there you know he's
giving you different levels completely
yeah it did come down to that level
right here
this point of control all right bounced
up a little bit to the value area high
came down dipped down again
it just gives you more levels right I
mean that's what trading is about is
seeing how markets react around levels
right I mean there's no law that says
you can't use you have to use it from
when the future is open right you could
use it from any point in time and
actually you know your starting point
it's kind of irrelevant right there's
people that use five day profiles
there's people that use monthly profiles
Etc right it's up to you as a Trader to
use the
the
who you want to call it right the the
way you find your levels is you know a
very intimate thing
let's take a look at another crude oil
okay crude oil
obviously uh we get crude here getting
the crew chart
crude oil interesting Market as well
right it's it's a lot of times it's all
up and down all over the place right you
can see on Friday 70 oh basically 72.80
High 70 20 low
but uh let's just go back to you know
some of these movements this is the high
of the day here just draw that line from
the high is the high here
to this low swing low okay where does it
come back to right here's your value
area low you value your high this is
your point of control
right you could just see it just came
Within
you know a couple of ticks here before
selling back down now
again you can take it from swings
I mean if you were to hold these levels
you could see it even came back right up
here and then sold off but you know you
could even take it from you know swings
sorry the swing low up to well there's a
swing high that made a new swing higher
swing low
um this swing High here right you can
see where's the value area I here this
is the value area low it's sold out from
this high down to the value area low
more or less this is 17 to get down to
99 before it rallied back up to 65 where
your value area high area is up in here
okay you can even you know draw it out
then you know once you know you've made
this as your swing High since you know
casual well the equity Cash open
um you know you could trace it down you
know watch it as it is it keeps going
lower right we made this new swing low
here
okay yeah nothing nothing much the
opponent control was down here the value
of your high was up here value area low
is here you know it's interesting your
opponent control came in below your
value area
which is a bearish sign but um you know
then made a new low right here
okay
what do you got right Market rallied
from your low up to your value area
um
oh you call it value area low and then
it sold off again
right so I mean there's just so many
different ways you could use it right
it's not about you know one way of using
it and you could anchor it from
um important
swing points right if you determine your
own swing levels or reversal points
right there's a reason why a market
reverses you know things in the market
change so sometimes you just you want to
focus on what's happened after sentiment
in the market has changed and most
obvious ones are numbers
um you know fed announcements or you
know if there's you know someone from
the FED is speaking in front of Congress
or something and says something
um you know during the course of the
trading day there's different areas on
the chart that you can draw an anchored
volume profile from
just as you would draw an anchored v-wap
from
okay so there's no one fixed way to use
it right it's flexible that's the beauty
of it it's a flexible profile and you
want to be watching where the volume is
forming after something
Market affecting hits the news wires or
hits the market and gets people to
change their
thoughts of what's happening in the
market so again you know if you're
interested in this tool it's part of
that ninja Caterers package uh become
involved with it's the uh
institutional their institutional Ed
system there's actually a bunch of tools
in here which you know you'll probably
see some more videos on in the future uh
one of the ones that I like obviously is
this real-time supply and demand it's
quite a beautiful tool
you know for finding Market support and
resistance
you know to me this one is is worth the
price of uh the whole package all
together
it's an expensive package don't get me
wrong it but it's you know there's like
30 30 Tools in there and you know the
beauty is it you can use this with order
flow as well right you know this is a
footprint chart
again you know if you were to draw out a
profile
you know from this swing High to here
you know it's giving me an area right I
can see in here this profile from the
swing High to the swing low you know
where I think you know I can see where
the volume is forming obviously I can
see that in the point of controls in
each bar
and I could just watch it as it's
trading you know back up towards those
levels
okay so I hope you guys enjoyed this
video and I'll see you guys on the next
one bye